don't run off to Canada I'm so boring
there that's Madonna weighing in on Meg
sit in a bizarre new video she posted to
Instagram on Tuesday last a month Prince
Harry joined wife Macon Markel and their
eight month old son Archie in Canada
following their bombshell decision to
step back as senior members of the royal
family the Sussex is plan to split their
time between the UK and Vancouver but
McDonough has a different idea in mind
I'll let him sublet my apartment in
Central Park West two-bedroom is the 61
year old singer is all about that view
no palaces Madonna is currently in
London on her madam X tour which could
be what's giving her inspo but
considering the singer's recent court
battle which reportedly legally requires
her to be present whenever guests stay
in her apartment
Madonna's Manhattan pad definitely
wouldn't give Megan in Harry the quieter
life they've been craving Harry really
is pushing on a brave face she's very
sad about leaving the United Kingdom the
decision that's I have made for my wife
and I to step back is not one I made
lightly
and I know I haven't always done it
right but as far as this goes there
really was no other option
I think the severity of what's happened
has had a huge impact on his brother on
his sister-in-law I think both of them
are are still reeling from the news
coming to terms with the reality of of
this situation but Prince William and
Kate Middleton seemed to be doing their
best to carry on business as usual the
duo was photographed carrying out
official business in South Wales on
Tuesday where Kate had a surprise
reunion with two of her childhood
teachers outside Joe's ice cream parlour
here's the 38 year old mom chatting with
st. Andrews prep school instructors
Denise Evans Alford and Kevin Alford
kate attended the school until she was
13 and Denise told Hello magazine she's
been waiting 20 years for this reunion
adding quote Kate hasn't changed at all
the reunion comes two days after the
Duchess of Cambridge stunned on the red
carpet at the 2020 BAFTAs
[Music]